bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat hier les sénateurs ont
adopté la proposition de loi du député
socialiste françois brottes sur la
transition énergétique sobre tout en
rejetant la principale disposition de ce
texte à savoir l'instauration d'un bonus
malus sur les tarifs de l'énergie
ce texte retournera donc à l'assemblée
nationale où cette fois les députés
auront le dernier mot
en attendant je vous propose ce matin de
revoir le rejet de l'article 1er qui
instaure donc un bonus malus pour
l'énergie bonne matinée à tous est mes
chers collègues la séance et reprises et
je vous rappelle la règle de l'entonnoir
ou de la seringue selon le président
raúl je rappelle donc en application de
l'article 48 alinéa 5 du règlement à
partir de la deuxième lecture au sénat
dès proposer des projets et propositions
de loi la discussion des articles est
limité à ceux pour lesquels les deux
assemblées du parlement n'ont pas encore
adopté une un texte identique en
conséquence son tir se valent les
amendements remettent en cause les
conformes ou les articles additionnels
sans relation directe avec les
dispositions restant en discussion
je vais donc mais trouve monsieur madame
la ministre je vous en prie monsieur le
président excusez moi parce que je
crains dans mon esprit j'avais bien
répondu à jean claude requier mais je
crois que ce n'était pas suffisamment
clair donc je souhaitais vous répondre
la réponse madame la ministre je vous en
prie relais zioui rattraper pour qu'il
n'y ait pas de malentendu monsieur le
président puisque
vous avez indiqué que vous craignez que
le système soit intrusif
donc c'est sur ce point j'ai indiqué que
les collectes de données c était limité
au strict minimum sous le contrôle de la
cnil
vous avez dit également qu'il faudrait
deux ans pour articuler le bonus malus
et la mise en place des travaux de
rénovation énergétique nous souhaitons
aller plus vite que deux ans sur les
travaux de rénovation énergétique et
defacto nous avons besoin en ce qui
concerne le déploiement du bonus malus
que la disposition législative soit
votée maintenant pour consacrer l'année
2013 à l'ensemble des textes
réglementaires qui vont devoir être pris
que 2014 permettent de faire la collecte
des données et les calculs de base pour
le déploiement du bonus malus qui
entrera en vigueur en 2015 et je vous
avais répondu aussi sur les autres
points de votre intervention
mais peut-être avait attribué cette
réponse à votre prédécesseur
donc je m'en excuse auprès de vous merci
madame la ministre monsieur le président
vous vouliez la parole vous lier la
parole monsieur le président alors je je
vais mettre aux voix
l'article premier à quels sont ceux qui
sont pour l'adoption de l'article 1er à
avis contraire il n'est pas adoptée
après l'article 1er à je suis saisi d'un
amendement sens de monsieur le noir
c'est monsieur le noir qui le défend le
président je ne sais pas si je me trompe
mais celle sentiment que la majorité de
gauche vient de repousser un élément du
texte qui se réfère à la précarité
énergétique donc je prends acte que la
droite a voté cette disposition que la
gauche l'a rejeté oui monsieur le
président je pense qu'il ya une erreur
dans la proposition de vote
effectivement sur le noir fait bien de
la relever
il y avait plein pouvez vous remercier
je vous saurais gré la prochaine fois
oui donc j'ai une dette envers vous si
je comprends bien il n'y avait pas
d'amendement sur l'arctique premier à
caen il est donc le vote ne devait
intervenir que sur l'adoption de
l'article
vous avez voté contre mais non666 nom de
à premier à n'a pas été adopté
et nous en arrivons donc après l'article
1er à l'amendement dont qui était
défendu par monsieur lenoir l'article
l'amendement 101 bien non mais pour la
bonne compréhension non pas des
personnes qui sont là parce que
finalement vous ai bien compris que vous
étiez trompés mais quand même des
personnes qui vont lire il était écrit
un alinéa que la politique menée par le
gouvernement dans le domaine et
d'énergie consistait notamment à lutter
contre la précarité énergétique confirme
que la droite a voté pour que la gauche
a voté contre alors l'amendement
l'amendement 101 porte sur la
péréquation tarifaire
je vous propose d'écrire dans la loire à
l'article elle s'en tirer 1 du code de
l'énergie que cette politique est menée
dans le respect des principes d'égalité
de continuité notamment au travers de la
péréquation nationale des tarifs de
vente d'électricité aux consommateurs
domestiques de l'harmonisation de ses
tarifs pour le gaz et de la péréquation
des tarifs d'utilisation des réseaux
publics de distribution
cette phrase n'est pas inventé c'est
tout simplement la phrase qui figure
dans la loi de 2004 qui est d'ailleurs
la première loi qui est ma connaissance
a vraiment préciser le contenu de la
notion de péréquation tarifaire
prenant la parole j'en profite pour
répondre à même les ministres qui me
veut observer tout à l'heure que le prix
d'électricité n'était pas le même selon
les communes puisque effectivement il ya
une taxe locale dont le taux est
variable selon les départements et selon
les communes
je parlais évidemment du prix hors taxe
alors votre intervention m'amène à vous
poser une question très précise
quelle est la nature juridique du malus
est ce que vous voulez insinuer que le
malus est une taxe non mais votre
réponse m'intéresse parce que
parce que dans l'avenir on ramené à
regarder les choses de près alors donc
je repose la question quelle est la
nature juridique du malus et notamment
est ce que c'est une taxe
merci monsieur le noir avis de la
commission monsieur le président
par rapport à l'amendement de monsieur
le noir on va bien commencer la soirée
c'est un avis favorable est en tous les
cas pas aux objectifs de la loi on est
complètement en face ce que vous écrivez
monsieur le noir merci monsieur le
président à vie du gouvernement madame
la ministre
défavorable monsieur le président je
rappelle que la péréquation nationale
des tarifs est déjà dans le code de
l'énergie à l'article 121 5
en ce qui concerne votre question je
pense que l'argumentation vous a touché
néanmoins sur la péréquation tarifaire
et la taxe que vous aviez oublié et donc
je vous réponds je vous renvoie l'avis
du conseil d'état qui à clarifier cette
question est d'ailleurs un certain
nombre des dispositions qui ont été
ajoutées à l'assemblée nationale dans
l'amendement qui réécrit le titre
premier à 6000 effectivement le bonus
malus à un système de taxation
comparable en tout point à la csp de ce
point de vue là merci madame la ministre
je vais donc mettre aux voix
l'amendement 101 qui a reçu l'avis
favorable du de la commission et l'avis
défavorable du gouvernement monsieur le
noir et ses explications de vote
madame le mini je vais relire nous
allons relire avec beaucoup d'attention
ce que vous ne les a indiqué à l'instant
vous ne pouvez pas comparer la cspe avec
le malus qui vient d'être institué
donc vous avez parlé d' une forme de
taxation je veux nous allons regarder ce
que recouvre cette cette réponse mais si
c'est une taxe ça implique un certain
nombre de conséquences je tiens à le
dire ici
merci je mets donc aux voix cet
amendement quels sont ceux qui sont pour
son adoption
avis contraire je n'en six avis
contraire il est adopté
après l'article 1er à l'amendement 102
toujours de monsieur lenoir monsieur le
noir rose et la parole oui merci
monsieur le président alors nous avons
dit à la tribune à 10 face aux assauts
ce qui moi même ainsi que d'autres
orateurs ne sommes évidemment contre le
système qui devait proposer par ce texte
bonus malus a pas eu d'étude d'impact
absolument aucun élément sur lequel nous
puissions nous fonder pour savoir
comment diriger ce véhicule mal
identifiées alors ce que nous proposons
nous c'est d'engager une procédure
d'expérimentation tout à fait comparable
à celle qui est inscrit dans le texte
concernant l'eau c'est à dire
conformément à l'article 72 de la
constitution
nous pourrions très bien engagé sur
cette incurie mentation pendant les
quelques années qui viennent je rappelle
que le dispositif qui devait fonctionner
dès novembre 2012
finalement ne fonctionnera qu'à partir
du début 2016 donc il ya du temps que
vous vous êtes donné
après réflexion nous vous proposons que
ce temps soit utilisé mis à profit pour
mettre en forme une expérimentation qui
nous permettrait d'avoir des
informations tout à fait intéressante
afin de consolider le dispositif s'il
mérite d'être mise en place
j'avais d'ailleurs dans le texte avec
mes amis proposé que l'expérimentation
puisse durer pendant cinq ans je pense
que c'est un peu long et donc si je peux
monsieur le président se demandait je
vais mettre plutôt trois années donc
c'est un premier sous un rendement et
ceux qui ensuite conduit à dire il sera
présenté par le gouvernement avant le 30
juin 2017
merci monsieur le noir monsieur le
président à vie de la commission donc
sur le sens de rectifier avec la
proposition de monsieur le noir monsieur
le noir je crois l'avoir évoquée dans la
discussion générale tout à l'heure ce
matin en commission nous avons eu une
faiblesse sur plutôt une ouverture
concernant le débat
sur ce texte je dois dire que votre
amendement à mon sens ils étaient
irrecevables concernant la jurisprudence
dans le cadre d'une nouvelle lecture
ce n'est pas dans le texte l'assemblée
nationale vous ne pouvez pas l'amendé
est donc pour moi je ne vous demanderai
de le retirer au sinon il était
irrecevable
non pas du tout ça concerne des
objectifs poursuivis par le texte
lui-même et ce n'est qu'un rappel par
rapport aux objectifs qui étaient
poursuivis par le texte de l'assemblée
nationale et donc inclus c'est une
précision je dirais le premier
amendement
le deuxième à mon sens est irrecevable
voilà merci à vis du gouvernement madame
la ministre
si nous sommes sur les questions de
procédures je pense que le précédent
était aussi re cela puisque c'était un
article additionnel
le gouvernement est défavorable à une
logique d'expérimentation nous voulons
mettre en place un bonus malus et pas
seulement
l'expérimenté et ensuite monsieur le
noir je vous renvoie vraiment à l'avis
du conseil d'état sur la question vous
avez posé tout à l'heure puisque le
conseil d'état dit très clairement que
le malus est un impôt dissuasif et que
le bonus est une aide
et donc si vous aviez un doute sur cette
question là le conseil d'état il y a
parfaitement répondu merci madame je
vais donc monsieur le noir simplement
pour poursuivre mais devrait rapidement
madame la ministre veut dire que c'est
un impôt qui est affecté la ressource de
saintes impôts est affecté aux personnes
donc forme de bonus dont voilà donc
c'est au journal officiel merci madame
la ministre
merci monsieur monsieur le président
vous confirmé l'irrecevabilité de de cet
amendement tendant en revanche attendu
je suis trop nouveau dans cette
assemblée pour connaître la réponse à la
question suivante à quel moment
l'irrecevabilité tel prononcée est ce
que c'est au moment du dépôt
d'amendements ou au moment où le discute
si c'est au moment du dépôt il constate
qu'il a été distribué donc on en a
discuté qu'il a de même été discuté en
commission ce matin
si en revanche il était dit que les
réseaux unités déclaré en cours de
séance j'aimerais savoir selon quelles
procédures
merci monsieur le président il ya
compris mais mon cher alain lenoir
c'est ce dont il s'agit effectivement je
vous ai dit que en commission j'aurais
dû le déclarer irrecevable je ne l'ait
pas fait dans un sens d'ouverture
je dois dire qu'à l'heure actuelle où je
veux demande le retrait ou c'est un avis
défavorable mais qu'à titre personnel
mon analyse est de dire qu'il était
irrecevable
ce n'est pas la même chose monsieur noir
l'amendement est retiré écoutez la
moisson que je retire des échanges qui
viennent d'être entendus et suffisamment
riche pour que j'abandonne
en revanche cet amendement merci mon
cher collègue l'amendement sens de
rectifier et retiré nous en arrivons
donc à l'article 1er et je suis saisie
de quatre demandes de parole dans celle
de monsieur capo-canellas qui n'est pas
là alors celle de monsieur jean jacques
mirassou vous avez la parole mon cher
collègue
merci monsieur le président madame
unissent
mes chers collègues je crois aux vertus
de la répétitivité en ce qui concerne le
volet pédagogique et manifestement il ya
encore fort à faire dans ce registre là
notamment par rapport à nos collègues de
l'opposition sénatoriale tout à l'heure
la discussion générale
j'ai eu l'occasion de souligner à juste
titre que l'article une telle qu'ils
étaient proposés avaient été nettement
améliorée par la lecture au niveau de
l'assemblée nationale tout en me
félicitant je le répète de l'abandon du
croisement des données des fournisseurs
mais c'est l'administration fiscale de
la rationalisation et la simplification
des critères de calcul des volumes de
base de la suppression du dispositif
relatif aux relations entre locataires
et propriétaires et surtout on
enregistre le fait que le malus ne
devient véritablement pénalisant qu'à
partir de trois fois le volume de base
de la consommation énergétique au lieu
de deux auparavant
une fois et demie cela va exactement
dans le sens que nous souhaitions et des
amendements dire est que nous avons dit
que nous avions déposé au cours de la
première lecture mais de nouvelles
améliorations je lis tout à l'heure peut
être encore à portée et c'est l'objet du
reste des amendements que nous proposons
dans la suite 2 mais dont la lucidité me
permet
de penser que leur espérance de vie va
s'amenuisant au fur et à mesure qu'on
s'approche des amendements dits de
suppression concernant l'article 1er le
bonus pour autant tel qu'il est conçu
non seulement est dépourvue d'effets
dire le mastiff je les dis aussi mais en
plus s'il ne profiterait pas en priorité
aux ménages modestes
bien au contraire le malus quant à lui
est précisément pourvu d'un rôle
incitatif pour diminuer les
consommations excessives et nous
proposons donc que son rendement ses
revenons pas alimenter un bonus qui ne
toucherait pas forcément les personnes
qui en ont le plus besoin
mais soit consacré à la politique
d'amélioration de la performance
énergétique des logements
ainsi on ferait en quelque sorte d'une
pierre deux coups d'une part taxer les
consommations excessives
d'autre part ont récupéré à travers le
fonds appelée formal us les sommes ainsi
dégagé pour aider les personnes en
situation de précarité énergétique qui
d'ailleurs je le rappelle encore le son
que symboliquement taxes et du fait
qu'elles bénéficieront de malus minoré
par ailleurs cette manière de faire
présente encore davantage de séparer
clairement la taxe sur les consommations
excessives des tarifs même de quoi
rassurer ceux qui a tort voyez mes chers
collègues dans le dispositif et leur
mise en cause de la péréquation
tarifaire avec un dispositif que nous
préconisons aucun doute là dessus on ne
touche pas à la récréation tarifaire la
suppression du bonus permettrait
également de simplifier encore
dispositif en évitant la constitution
d'un conte d'équilibrage complexe et
porteur des faits difficilement
prévisibles les sommes prélevées sur le
fond seront celles qui ont été
effectivement collecté et non celle qui
serait estimé à partir de tout calcul a
priori sans correspondre toujours a
posteriori au montant effectivement
collecté
enfin et c'est un avantage important
la suppression du bonus sur la tranche
de consommation inférieur au volume de
base conduit logiquement à supprimer
pour les malus pourtant sur la tranche
intermédiaire de façon à ne pas
pénaliser les ménages qui n'ont pas une
consommation démesurée
l'objectif étant aussi et surtout de
déconnecter les logements énergivores
il paraît plus judicieux de mettre en
place un système d' alerte à destination
de l'organisme pour prier lorsque la
consommation dépasse 250 % du volume de
base télé dans le sens de la
présentation que nous entendions donner
à cet article premier qui va dans le
sens d'une simplification accrue
puis le plus grande efficacité avec un
dispositif visant la détection des
logements énergivores et l'amélioration
de la performance énergétique via le
fonds des mollusques et en même temps je
veux permet d'espérer que nous aurons
l'opportunité de faire vivre ce débat si
le couple est annoncé par les uns et par
les autres ne viennent pas justement les
interrompre
si mon cher collègue monsieur le noir
vous avez la parole
oui monsieur le président je n'avais pas
envisagé de parler maintenant puisque
j'ai déposé un certain nombre
d'amendements sur l'article 1er mai la
remarque de fond collègue jean jacques
mirassou me laisse à penser qu'il faut
être lucide et que si on a quelque chose
à dire et il vaut mieux le faire
maintenant que de constater qu'il y a eu
un article en moins et que les
amendements sur lesquels nous voulons
intervenir ont disparu alors je reviens
sur l'organisme haddock l'hippocampe
éléphanteaux cadets loos alors d'abord
une première question madame a minima
sans de me répondre
elle nous avait dit dans le débat erdf
moi je me souviens qu'en commission en
octobre la dernière vous aviez évoqué
cette hypothèse en disant que vous
l'aviez écartée car elle était trop
coûteuse et c'est dans le compte rendu
de la commission je peux le tenir
disposition gellért lui tout à l'heure
deuxième question toujours à propos de
rdf est-ce que edf est ce qu edf
d'ailleurs l'actionnaire principal et
unique
erdf sont au courant de ceux qui
éventuellement se prépare je ne connais
absolument pas la réponse
alors maintenant sur le coup de
l'hippocampe éléphanteaux camelo ce
parce que j'ai bien entendu rapporteur
nous a dit en commission
le malus va rapporter 200 millions
d'euros et le coût de gestion ça va être
50 millions mais je me fais fort par un
amendement de le faire tomber à 20
millions en moi je reprends le texte qui
vient de l'assemblée nationale et je
regarde tout ce qui lie à faire que ce
soit edf ou un autre organisme créé pour
la circonstance
le travail sera le même somme est assez
bref
à l'invitation de l'organisme les
consommateurs déclare annuellement
auprès de ce dernier avant le 1er mai
les informations nécessaires et c'est
donc déjà il ya une lettre qui s'en va
combien y at-il de personnes en fin de
de foyers concernés 30 millions une
simple lettre à moins de 20 grammes il y
en a déjà pour 15 millions simplement
pour inviter les personnes à remplir une
déclaration que dit le texte
ensuite si les personnes ne répondent
pas je m'arrête un instant j'ai regardé
auprès d'un certain nombre d'organismes
qui collecte d'informations quel est le
taux de retour après une simple lettre
les informant qu'ils doivent répondre le
retour est de 30% et au bout de cinq ans
il est de 70%
c'est à dire qu'il ya un certain nombre
de gens qui vont se mettre dans la
situation qui est décrite après s'ils ne
répondent pas eh bien eh bien eh bien il
y à l'envoi d'une lettre en recommandé
voilà lettre recommandée avec demande
d'avis de réception
il y en à peu près seulement 30% qui
vont répondre 70% n'ont pas fait 70% de
30 millions de clients
ça vous fait 20 millions de clients vous
savez quel est le coût d'une lettre avec
accusé de réception
il est vérifié encore tout à l'heure à
la poste 4 euros 46 coût 90 millions
d'euros
je me suis renseigné d'autre part pour
connaître le
coûts liés à la manipulation des lettres
qu'on met sous enveloppe on porte et
cetera c'est 60 centimes d'euro par pli
18 millions d'euros ça veut dire que la
première année alors que seulement 30 %
de clients répondu ça vous coûte 2 alors
attendez ça vous coûte 123 millions
d'euros mais il faut y ajouter les
personnes qui sont dans l'organisme
les personnes qui traitent les
informations les transmettent et ses
terrains et puis évidemment évidemment
les personnes qui seront contrôlés
alors pour savoir comment ça vous pouvez
écouter
j'ai regardé ce que coûtait le centre de
perception de la redevance de la
télévision qui a été supprimé il ya
quelques années
et là dessus j'ai des renseignements
intéressants parce qu'il me viennent de
la commission des finances de
l'assemblée nationale
et c'est un rapport présenté par
monsieur didier migaud était à l'époque
membre de cette commission et à l'époque
pour 10 700 personnes et tout le monde
s'accorde à dire que pour votre vin
il faudra encore beaucoup plus de
bergues du goût des fruits charitables
on va s'en tenir à ça à l'époque
compte tenu du chiffre qui est annoncé
en millions de francs
ces 125 millions d'euros alors excusez
moi de faire des calculs devant vous
sans avoir de tableau la première année
compte tenu du déficit de réponse que
j'annonçais le coût de l'opération ses
248 millions d'euros est en bonne année
parce que finalement 70% des personnes
répondent
eh bien on passe à 203 millions d'euros
la recette attendue était de 200
millions d'euros
ah vous voyez que vous avez un système
extraordinaire pour lutter contre le
chômage
vous prélevée sur les factures
d'électricité et recrée un organisme qui
va ensuite vérifié c'est les gens
remplissent bien les formulaires
nécessaires à l'établissement de leur
facture
alors franchement alors d'abord il ya
plus de bonus alors ça le bonus il est
complètement manger par ce malus et par
ses coups sûrs seulement exorbitants
mais d'ailleurs et j'en termine là
monsieur le président c'est ce que
madame la ministre nous avait dit devant
la commission
c'est mon cher collègue la parole est un
monsieur françois fortassin pour le
groupe rdse
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues au delà du vote que
nous et mettront en scène dans notre
groupe
je voudrais dire madame la ministre
qu'il faut un esprit aussi lumineux que
le vôtre pour comme vraiment quelque
chose à ce texte et je plein beaucoup
les usagers ou les clients lorsqu'ils
vont recevoir les éléments savoir que
les hommes auront un malus
les autres bonus ceux qui auront un
malus seront prêts à toutes les
contestations parce qu'ils auront rien
gombries et ceux qui auront un bonus
seront très satisfait de payer moins
mais il sort pas pourquoi en définitive
ce texte
c'est un texte extrêmement
bureaucratique je m'excuse pour mes amis
communistes ça m'a fait penser à la
bureaucratie qu'on avait jadis un pays
de l'est et qu'il a pas donné les
meilleurs résultats et il s'agit bien de
cela
ensuite il y a aussi un autre élément ya
ce que ne dit pas le texte
rien par exemple sur les déperditions
d'énergie du fait d'un mauvais entretien
des réseaux
pas un mot n'a été dit sur les syndicats
départementaux d'électricité de
l'énergie qui font pourtant un travail
extrêmement important au niveau de
l'amélioration de ses réseaux et si les
réseaux se dégrade et bien à l'évidence
on l'on a ça a été un coup d'épée dans
l'eau puisque il y aura de toutes façons
de fortes déperditions d'énergie dont du
gaspillage r
et enfin l'autre élément on n'a rien dit
non plus de ceux qui qui sommes de plus
en plus nombreux notamment dans les
régions méridionales de notre pays qui
utilise beaucoup la climatisation en été
et cet clim
aujourd'hui leur fait dépenser beaucoup
plus large en quelque sorte que le
chauffage en hiver
là encore je n'ai rien vu dans le texte
qui peut qu'ils puissent eux nous
éclairer sur cette affaire-là et je
dirais que si vous avez tenté de nous
éblouir nous sommes va pourtant éclairé
malade ni merci mon cher collègue je
suis saisie de trois amendements
identiques de suppression faisant
l'objet d'une discussion commune mais je
vais donner la parole à monsieur le
président je reconnais la finesse de
raisonnement notre collègue le noir mais
je dois dire monsieur le noir que vous
déformez les chiffres les chiffres que
j'ai donné en commission ne concernait
que le malus
autrement dit vous ne pouvez pas faire
le calcul sur les 30 millions dont
bonnet laisser simplement sur le dernier
quart t-il éventuellement qui
dépasserait les 300 % et donc vous ne
pouvez pas faire ce calcul sur les 30
millions d'abonnés
est ce que je vous ai dit c'est que le
coût de gestion estimé par rapport au
document jeudi visait par quatre par
rapport à ce qui avait été évoqué à
l'assemblée nationale puisque il ne
restait plus que 25 % des abonnés à
traiter éventuellement donc pardon non
mais vous faites un calcul sur
l'ensemble des abonnés alors que le
malus que je vous avais donné en
commission ne portait que sur le dernier
quart t-il voilà une précision longuet
merci monsieur le président je suis je
t'écoute ce texte parce que je n'ai pas
le neures le bonheur d'appartenir à la
commission compétente mais il ya quand
même un problème de chiffres si on se
bat même sur le dernier quartier de
sheikh président raoul ça fait quand
même 7 million et demi de consommateurs
s'il s'agit de répartir 200 millions un
rapide calcul même conduit à penser que
ça fait on parle de 30 euros par an et
par consommateur
tout ça pour ça merci nous en arrivons
donc à la discussion des trois
amendements
madame la ministre vous lie à la parole
j'ai été tenté de dire monsieur le noir
mis une solution si on fait rien on
reste les bras croisés on regarde ce qui
se passe mais non et non et je voulais
vous indiquer que les débats il n'y a
pas de coût de gestion dans la mesure où
le mécanisme de bonus malus
s'autofinance y compris l'administration
du système
premier point deuxième point ce que je
comparais en commission c'était le coup
de la jce gestion par l'administration
fiscale
comparé à la gestion par un organisme
haddock et donc la nuit le choix qui a
été fait suite à un certain nombre de
remarques de parlementaires qui ont
d'ailleurs auditionné notamment à erdf
c'est de le confier à un groupe haddock
qui pourra être un gip qui pourra être
le rdf si jamais erdf le souhaitent
ce n'est pas quelque chose qui soit
décidée aujourd'hui la précision que je
voulais vous donner c'est que les
estimations qui sont faites c'est que
les coûts de gestion du bonus malus ont
strictement les mêmes que les coûts de
gestion des tarifs sociaux c'est à dire
à peu près 5% des sommes qui sont en jeu
pas davantage et donc il n'y a pas en
rente retenir de fantasmes sur les coûts
faramineux de ce système
merci madame la ministre mandement
numéro de madame cherche monsieur le
président madame la ministre mes chers
collègues cet article un bien que
réécrit conserve intact le principe
d'une modulation du tarif en fonction du
niveau de consommation et
de la localisation or la population nous
l'avons largement soulignée composé de
ménage hétérogène il est impossible de
calculer à volume de références adaptées
à chaque consommateur et ce malgré
toutes les exceptions que vous pourriez
intégrer dans ce dispositif la loi se
doit pourtant d'être au plus proche de
la réalité le droit n'est pas une pure
abstraction de plus nous continuons nous
ne sommes pas les seuls à questionner
voire nier la pertinence de ce
dispositif tant en termes écologiques
économiques que sociaux associations de
consommateurs et du look aux salariés du
secteur économistes universitaires de
tous bords bailleurs sociaux tous nous
ont interpellé
pourquoi le principe tarifaires que vous
nous présentez comme une évidence
n'est-il pas universellement reconnus
pourquoi la belgique l'allemagne
l'italie ont abandonné le projet alors
que leurs habitudes de consommation sont
proches des nôtres
tout simplement parce que le dispositif
proposé est inefficace dans ses trois
volets est trop complexe à mettre en
oeuvre pour la sobriété le pari
progressiste et progressive qui ne
concerne que les ménages est pas le
secteur tertiaire ne permettra pas comme
vous le souhaitez madame la ministre je
vous cite la réalisation d'économies
d'énergie massive pire il peut entraîner
des effets contre productifs
c'est le fameux effet rebond en effet
d'une manière perverse le bonus croix
avec la consommation dans les limites du
volume de base c'est donc une incitation
à consommer si par exemple volume de
base de deux volumes de référence et 100
et je consomme habituellement 60 parce
que je suis attentive à ma facture comme
la majorité nos concitoyens et en
consommant 95 et en peux plus je
bénéficie alors d'un super bonus
pourquoi dès lors en privé avec ce
dispositif les ménages les plus malins
augmenteront leur consommation jusqu'à
atteindre le plafond du volume autorisé
les autres percevront un bonus -
importance ils en perçoivent 1
de plus ce système récompensera des
ménages aisés habitant une maison neuve
est bien isolé
le dispositif ne prend pas en compte la
pointe de consommation
le coût économique et environnemental de
l'électrique
ite dépend surtout de l'heure et du jour
où elle est consommée et pas seulement
du volume total de la consommation
il faut dès lors inciter les
consommateurs à consommer différemment
dans le temps en promouvant une offre de
grille tarifaire plus adapté aux
réalités de vie de nos concitoyens
c'est un peu le cas mais ce n'est pas
extraordinairement valoriser enfin pour
que l' équilibre financier du dispositif
soit assurée il faudrait un malus élevé
toucherait suffisamment de foyers pour
compenser le bonus et les frais de
fonctionnement du dispositif dont nous
venons de parler or il est répété à
l'envi que le malus ne touchera que très
peu de foyers
pour le moment les volumes il est palier
des bonus du bonus malus pouvant être
modifiée par voie réglementaire
vous nous demandez donc de voter un
blanc seing pour toutes ces raisons nous
vous invitons à voter notre amendement
de suppression et madame amendement
numéro 27 monsieur le noir oui monsieur
le président on en tirer aucune
conclusion mais je trouve que
l'argumentation qui a été développé par
notre collègue dan church est parfait
parfaite
en fait les arguments que vous avancez
sont tout à fait leno donc encore une
fois
n'allez pas raconté après que nous
sommes en train de vous épauler contre
contre le gouvernement en place
nous faisons preuve de pragmatisme
en réalité je pars reprendre les
arguments vous avez bien compris que
nous sommes tout à fait aussi à ce
dispositif extrêmement compliquée qui va
pénaliser
alors je reviens d'ailleurs sur ce point
madame ne me dis pas ce que me v10 à les
personnes qui bénéficient des tarifs
sociaux ne seront pas touchés mais vous
m'avez mal entendu vous reverrez en
fille vivent tellement vous relisez mon
intervention
j'ai parlé des foyers modestes parce que
il ya une catégorie qui va encore payer
ce sont les foyers modestes les classes
moyennes alors ces personnes vont
effectivement être plus grande victime
de ce système
alors nous sommes contre et donc nous
allons évidemment voté cet amendement de
suppression avec toutes les conséquences
que cela implique mais madame la
ministre vous nous avez dit a finalement
comme ce système est mauvais selon vo
que vont ils faire et vous avez suggéré
qu'on ne fasse rien
non vous avez dit on ne fait rien si on
est content ça veut dire qu'on ne fait
rien bon je vais vous répondre
et c'est là où il ya un décalage
important entre votre façon de regarder
ce problème est la nôtre aujourd'hui le
problème souligné la tribune
en france c'est la pointe en terme de
consommation c'est la pointe
c'est elle qui coûte cher et c'est elle
qui d'ailleurs produit le plus de co2
que si vous prenez le nucléaire c'est
quasiment un ruban de même forme du
matin au soir
en revanche la variable d'ajustement
c'est le gaz et le charbon ou peut le
vérifier en regardant les graphiques de
rte tous les jours d'autre part
contrairement à une idée reçue le prix
de l'électricité n'est pas le même dans
la journée ce que coûte électricité
n'est pas le même niveau le matin midi
l'après midi le soir la nuit et c est
finalement eu une vraie politique qui
viserait à économiser de l'énergie
notamment
l'autre part de l'électricité c'est une
politique qui agissent non pas en aval
du compteur comme vous le proposez dans
ce texte mais en amont c'est à dire que
le client prendre et de l'énergie en
fonction des offres qui lui sont faites
continue du prix marginal de
l'électricité le jour la nuit dans la
semaine et cetera de façon qu'ils
puissent adapter son mode de
consommation à l'offre qui est fait et
pour ça il faut un maillon important
c'est le compteur communicant
nous avons mené avec lundi sap d'atos
qu'une mission avec l'ancien
gouvernement dont la conclusion qui
était d'ailleurs validé par beaucoup et
est que nous avions besoin en france de
ce compteur communicant alors je pense
que vous avez eu l'occasion de regarder
ce dossier il est éminemment sensible
si vous demandez à verdun car c'est
votre responsabilité d'engager processus
de fabrication et d'installation des
compteurs communicants alors là on
dispose on dispose d'un outil
qui permettra aux clients d'être
vraiment responsable là vous lui
demander de regarder
l'année d'après sa consommation s'il a
bien fait ou s'il a mal fait et c'est
dans ces conditions qu'il est pénalisé
qui sentira injustement pénalisés
j'ajoute enfin c'est le dernier argument
franchement comme l'a dit avec beaucoup
de pertinence gérard longuet tout ça
pour finalement apporté à bonus en
moyenne de 30 euros par an aux clients
qui ne dépasserait pas le cadre
administrativement fixée par un certain
nombre de décrets d'arrêter franchement
c'est un dispositif qui est complètement
décalé l'énormité de ce dispositif avec
l'organisme haddock et les fantômes
eepocampe éléphanteaux cas mais l'os
tout ça conduit à dire non non et non il
faut mettre par terre
cette disposition et amendements 67
monsieur merceron merci monsieur le
président comme les deux précédents
présenté par nos collègues des groupes
ump src
cet amendement pour objet de supprimer
l'article 1er la proposition de loi je
l'indiquais lors de la discussion
générale
les sénateurs du groupe udi us et
partagent des objectifs de sobriété de
performance énergétique
la lutte contre la précarité énergétique
doit être une priorité mais pour cela il
faut commencer par améliorer
l'efficacité des logements et
accompagner les ménages dans la maîtrise
de leur consommation cela passe par des
aides à l'isolation de l'habitat et par
le développement des compteurs dits
intelligents
nous n'acceptons pas l'instauration de
ce bonus malus pour les trois raisons
suivantes
d'une part il est injuste car ce sont
souvent les plus faibles et les plus
précaires qui vont devoir payer le malus
terre vivent dans des logements
passoires
alors que les plus aisés qui pourront
isoler leurs logements bénéficieront
d'un bonus
d'autre part le mécanisme n'arrive pas
au bon moment il faut d'abord
accompagner les ménages
il faut aussi attendre les conclusions
du débat national sur la transition
énergétique
enfin il est complexe même dans sa
nouvelle rédaction le dispositif n'est
pas intelligible et on peut même
s'interroger sur sa constitutionnalité
pour toutes ces raisons nous souhaitons
que le bonus disparaissent bonus et
malus disparaissent du texte merci mon
cher collègue jeu
donc on voit ces trois amendements je me
demande de parole oui je le lave
pardonnez-moi l'avis de la commission du
gouvernement pardonnez moi monsieur le
président la commission a émis ce matin
un avis favorable trois amendements à
mon corps défendant
merci monsieur le président à vie du
gouvernement madame la ministre
d'abord je voulais dire à madame change
que l'objectif du bonus c'est que
l'énergie soit moins cher et est que cet
objectif est atteint lorsqu'on lorsqu'on
est dans une consomme 75 % des français
3 français sur 4 payeront leur énergie
d'électricité et de gaz bénéficieront du
bonus et donc la payeront de fait moins
cher par rapport à ce que vous avez dit
sur sur l'effet rebond
ensuite je voulais
parler de la pointe puisque monsieur le
noir bien vite et donc je rappellerai
que dix ans de droite ça a été 28 %
d'augmentation de la pointe
c'est ça le bilan auquel nous devons
faire face aujourd'hui est donc
effectivement une priorité d'action du
gouvernement c'est la lutte contre la
pointe et nous développons toutes les
solutions monsieur le mans l'avons lama
l'amont l'aval toutes les dimensions
l'effacement exactement le déploiement
des smart grid
nous allons traiter ça dans le débat
national sur la transition énergétique
les réseaux intelligents les compteurs
intelligents qui était un dossier
passionnant mais un projet complètement
plombé par le précédent gouvernement
puisque c'est ça la réalité puisque j'ai
hérité d'une situation dans lesquels
bien sûr que oui
dans lesquels sur le projet du
déploiement des compteurs n'écoute
madame la ministre
chers collègues de consommateurs étaient
vent debout contre ce conteur et tout le
travail que nous essayons de faire est
qu'une méthodiquement patiemment nous
avons refait c'est de reconstruire un
consensus national autour du compteur
linky et si vous êtes favorable à ce
projet je vous en remercie et nous avons
même fait madame analystes ne se connaît
tous ce qu'ils écoutent malama minister
linky où c'est la réalité
monsieur poniatowski c'est la réalité
c'est la réalité
mais je suis entrain de mes chers
collègues vous écoutez madame la
ministre je donnerai la parole si vous
le souhaitez soit un outil au service
des consommateurs que ce soit un outil
de la politique de maîtrise de l'énergie
et que ce soit un outil qui permette à
chaque citoyen choix de consommateurs
aussi de savoir en temps réel où il en
est de sa consommation d'énergie et où
il en est du bonus malus puisqu'il y
aura même des applications qui
permettront sus sur smartphone sur
ordinateur de suivre en temps réel sa
consommation d'énergie c'est ça qui va
être déployé
merci madame la ministre je vais donc
mettre aux voix
c'est trois amendements monsieur
mirassou souhaité la parole je vous la
donne oui c'est ça de la discussion
mes chers collègues je serais tenté de
dire que nos collègues
la droite sénatoriale en fait quand même
un peu trop comment l'expliquer chers
collègues le noir qui à moins de dix
minutes vous avez préconisé de tester
peu dingue
pas moins de cinq années un dispositif
que vous empresser de disqualifier
cinq minutes après par le biais de
l'amendement de suppression
parce que voter l'amendement de
suppression ça revient effectivement à
annihiler tout ce qui est en amont en
termes de dispositifs dont encore une
fois vous préconisez qu'ils sont à
l'essai pendant cinq ans et comme je le
lis ce matin en commission
plutôt que de proposer une
expérimentation de cinq ans vous aurez
méfier de la réduire à 5 minutes me voir
à cinq secondes
ensuite quand même vous avez les uns et
les autres
déployer une argumentation qui est une
augmentation à charge
ce qui veut dire que le principe qui a
été le vôtre j'ai failli dire le
postulat ça a été le dire on vote contre
contre tout et ensuite on va essayer de
trouver les explications
y aurait-il quand même dans tous ces
arguments quelque chose vous permettant
par un réflexe serait tenté de dire de
bon sens de le voter
vous l'auriez voté contre quand même
c'est à dire que vous dites non non non
et non
et la problématique halak et à laquelle
nous sommes confrontés de délestage
parle est d'ailleurs que vous avez
évoqué vous même c'est le dire qu'il ya
une situation qui est maintenant entre
abl pour bon nombre de nos concitoyens
et moi je vous parlais monsieur le noir
d'une famille que je ne connais pas qui
habite par contre dans une cité que je
connais bien qui s'appelle la cité
remorque s'est situé au coeur de mon
canton ou parce qu'effectivement ces
gens là on va faire à des propriétaires
peu scrupuleux
il habite dans un habitat années 60 où
il n'est pas question de compteurs linky
où il n'est pas question d'isolation où
il n'est pas question de charme il est
question ne rien et ces gens là qui plus
est on les a dotés de radiateur qui se
ressemblent à des grille-pain parce que
c'était la solution technique que la
moins onéreuse et d'hommes il passe
l'hiver
à regarder le radiateur qui ne peuvent
pas lui mais parce que tout simplement
ils n'ont pas les ressources financières
pour le faire et au moment où je parle
jeudi avec un peu de masse il me semble
que vous sauter avec beaucoup de
facilité à pieds joints par dessus écart
que je viens d'évoquer
s'agissant de l'obsession que vous
manifestez par rapport aux contrôles
linky j'ai également l'occasion de vous
rappeler tout il ya quelques temps que
même si même si cette opportunité la
limite les payes d'intéressantes elle
s'adressera quand même deux fêtes
préférentiellement à ceux qui sont sur
le plan énergétique
de l'autre côté de l'éventail qui ont
toutes les dispositions pour avoir en
termes de performance thermique
l'habitation convenable le plus souvent
d'ailleurs qui ont également une voiture
hybride et qui par l'intermédiaire d'un
conteur se donneront les moyens d'être
encore plus performant en allant
vérifier qui vous met décidément faire
la vaisselle
à 11h38 cas 12h43
ces gens là monsieur le moment où je
parle je ne m'intéresse pas parce que je
l'évoqué tout à l'heure par le biais des
faits rebonds on pourra également
peut-être les inciter à consommer
davantage
l'obsession qui la nôtre je veux dire
l'obsession qui la nôtre c'est de
prendre en compte
je vais pas dire avec commisération mais
tous qu'avec un peu d'intérêt le sort de
sa famille que j'évoquais tout à l'heure
qui habite à citéa murube dans le canton
celle de la ville de toulouse et des
sites et amoureuse comme dans la canton
16 à 12
il y en a des centaines et des centaines
et à force disqualifier la discussion
parce que rien ne vous empêchait en
menant le débat au-delà de l'article que
vous sanctionnez d'apporter que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure en termes
d'intelligence collective pour peu que
manifestent un peu de bonne foi pour
tirer ce texte vers le haut j'ai cru
comprendre que pour de multiples raisons
vous étiez quand même spécialiste de ce
secteur d'activité et je pense que
l'argumentation que vous avez déployés
jusqu'à maintenant en faisant la
démonstration que vous étiez équipés
intellectuellement sur ce dossier n'a
pas été tellement productive pour les
gens dont nous avons encore une fois au
coeur de au coeur de notre préoccupation
la vie qui s'en sont un peu quoi et vous
n'arriverez pas vous dédouaner
unis comme en disant ah oui mais on va
se tenir une bonne conduite avec le
titre 2 non non ça suffira pas et nous
le trouverons le politique veut
seulement se le dire avec un peu de
force ce que je suis en train de dire
est que j tout à l'heure à discussions
initiales et que nous tous nous diront
d'ailleurs à tous les gens concernés
c'est de faire en sorte qu' on puisse
aller un peu de silence et l'immobilisme
plus total nous a fait des calculs
chiffres est là avec une règle à calcul
coude dans la poche ou que vous l'avez
pas mais j'ai très sincèrement c'est pas
la démonstration que vous avez fait la
démonstration des temps de vous c'est un
geste politique pour faire en sorte
qu'on sorte de l'ornière
merci mon cher collègue madame cherche
oui monsieur le président je veux
simplement essayé de démontrer que nous
ne sommes pas dans une position
dogmatique
donc je les dis mais notre rapporteur le
sénateur daniel raoul le dit lui même
dans son rapport je cite
s'agissant dit-il écrit-il du mécanisme
dans son ensemble votre commission a
considéré qu'en dépit des améliorations
ce dispositif demeurait trop complexe et
qu'il était porteur d' injustice pour
certaines catégories de consommateurs
notamment les ménages à faibles revenus
ou les personnes âgées
je cite notre rapporteur nous
considérons nous que le bonus malus
risque en effet de sanctionner des
personnes qui n'auront pas d'autre choix
de consommer un certain volume d'énergie
sauf à renoncer complètement à une vie
décente
deuxième argument je l' ai déjà dit à
notre avis ce dispositif n'est pas le
bon dispositif pour faire baisser sa
consommation d'énergie alors bien sûr
ceux qui ont une maison parfaitement
isolés pourront le faire ce qu'ils
savent bien réfléchir et comprendre les
différents tarifs ils le feront mais
grand nombre de personnes ne seront
n'est pas armé pour faire baisser sa
consommation uniquement sur ce point le
la localisation géographique nous pose
un problème
en effet et donc nous considérons que ce
n'est pas non plus
un bon critère on introduit les
différentes catégories d'usagers en
fonction de ce critère géographique et
donc cela induira ont pris pas du
kilowattheure mais la facture
la facture énergétique va augmenter
alors que ces personnes qui habitent
dans des zones froides par exemple sont
déjà largement exposée à un malus de
fait puisque la leur facture augmente
par rapport à une personne qui habite
dans une zone plus chaudes
alors nous la seule exception à
l'égalité devant le service public
ce que nous pouvons concevoir c'est
celle qui tend vers la vraie égalité en
gommant l'inégalité sociale par le
soulagement tarifaire nous allons y
revenir
ensuite je ne comprends pas l'urgence
dans la nouvelle version la date
d'application est repoussée à 2015 les
premiers bonus malus 2016
donc nous ne comprenons pas pourquoi on
persiste à vouloir voter ici un
dispositif dans l'urgence alors que la
mise en application est reporté de deux
ans merci madame jeu monsieur le
président je souhaiterais que madame
cherche considère avec beaucoup
d'attention mais adducteurs je n'ai fait
que rapporter le prince la position de
la majorité de l'acompte de la
commission et vous pouvez pas ma putté
ces termes là je fais déjà un numéro
spécial mais nous n'exagérons pas
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre
oui je voulais indiqué parce que c'est
un point et qui est revenu souvent dans
les discussions que la nouvelle version
du titre premier permet d'éviter tout
risque que le malus est un effet pervers
au plan social et je renvoie en
particulier à l'alinéa 82 de l'article
1er qui permet précisément de d'avoir
des dispositions de malus ramené à
l'euro symbolique pour les personnes
bénéficiaires des tarifs sociaux
ça c'est la première chose la deuxième
c'est le fait on est remonté le seuil du
malus réel à 300% évite les effets
pervers qui avait été longuement discuté
en première lecture est vraiment les
modifications qui ont été apportées
visent à ce qu'il n'y ait pas ces effets
pervers qui aurait pu concerner des
personnes qui habitaient des passoires
des passoires thermiques donc vraiment
je pense que cette préoccupation a été
entendu et ne fait donc plus d'obstacle
à l'adoption de l'article 1er merci
madame
je vais donc mettre aux voix les trois
amendements 2,27 et 67 et je suis saisi
d'une demande de scrutin public
nous allons donc procéder au scrutin
public et j'invite mesdames et messieurs
les secrétaires à bien vouloir procéder
à ce scrutin
le scrutin est ouvert
plus personne ne demande à voter le
scrutin clos et j'invite mesdames et
messieurs les secrétaires a procédé au
dépouillement
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
je vous donne lecture du résultat du
scrutin numéro 100 sur les amendements
2,27 et 67 nombre de votants 347 nombre
de suffrages exprimés 347 majorité
absolue des suffrages exprimés 174 pour
l'adoption 208 contre 139 le sénat a
donc adopté ces trois amendements de
suppression et en conséquence donc
l'article premier tomb ait supprimé
pardon monsieur le président monsieur le
président monsieur le président j'ai une
suggestion à vous faire évidemment par
voie de conséquence l'article 1er bis
premier maire et premier quater non non
non non n'allez pas trop vite monsieur
monsieur planète ski mais j'ai bien
compris qu'il fallait un vote sur chacun
des suppressions mais on pourrait aller
très vite et je demande à mes collègues
y compris du groupe socialiste par
conséquence de voter ces amendements de
suppression ou de s'abstenir mais c'est
une cohérence par rapport au vote qui
vient d'intervenir
merci monsieur le président donc article
1er bis deux amendements 41 et 40 et 82
en discussion commune qui sont des
amendements identiques de suppression
monsieur noir il est défendu vraiment
pour moi il tombé puisqu'il se réfère à
l'article 1er sont contenues et
complètement vidé donc si vous voulez
vraiment que je le défends je veux bien
vous permettez je donne un avis
favorable de la commission à la
suppression de ces trois articles comme
ça c'est clair madame cher je voulais la
parole il est défendu bien je vais donc
mettre aux voix c'est deux amendements
41,82 que reçu favorable aussi les
gouvernements défavorable comment bien
donc je les mets au wat
quels sont ceux qui sont pour leur
adoption
des amendements oui oui monsieur
poniatowski avis contraire je n'en vois
pas dans clean le groupe socialiste ne
prend pas part au vote
donc l'article 1 bis l'article 1er bis
est supprimée et nous en arrivons à
l'article 1er terre avec deux
amendements identiques 44,83 même vote
même vote
il assume donc l'article 1er terre est
supprimé nous en arrivons à l'article
1er quater avec un amendement
deux amendements pardon de monsieur le
noir et de madame cherche même vote même
vote
en conséquence donc l'article premier
cas terre tombe mes chers collègues
madame il est je vais donc suspendre la
séance elle sera reprise à 21h30 donc
pour la suite de l'examen de ce texte
la séance est suspendue c'est la fin de
cette séance merci à vous de l'avoir
suivi si vous souhaitez en savoir plus
sur ce texte notre site internet
publicsenat.fr très belle journée à tous